have you ever heard someone call birds
living dinosaurs
you might find that hard to believe
after all the city pigeons that you see
wandering around town don't look
particularly ferocious like a
tyrannosaurus rex
but it turns out that our feathered
friends are actually the direct
descendants of a group of dinosaurs that
lived millions of years ago
birds like every modern species have a
series of ancestors stretching back
through time you can think of these as
the species grandparents
great-grandparents
great-great-grandparents and so on going
back thousands to millions of years
this series of ancestors is called a
species evolutionary lineage
and also like every modern species birds
have related species that share part of
their lineage but then branch off on
their own evolutionary path
the modern bird lineage stretches way
back to 165 million years ago to the
jurassic period
during this time iconic dinosaurs like
the stegosaurus and brachiosaurus roamed
the earth as well as distant relatives
of our modern day birds like
archaeopteryx and anchiornis
both archaeopteryx and anchiornis among
other birdlike dinosaurs are considered
some of the first birds based on their
long arms feathered bodies wings and
other physical characteristics that are
shared by all birds
but all birds both modern day species
and these earlier bird relatives that
lived in the distant past
all trace their evolutionary lineage
back to a common ancestor which is an
ancestral group of organisms that is
shared by one or more lineages
in other words any of the modern birds
that you see today whether it's a dove
or a penguin they all evolved from the
same bird-like dinosaur ancestor
evolutionary trees can be used to show
the relationships between different
lineages like different bird species and
their common ancestors
scientists build evolutionary trees
using various lines of evidence such as
examining fossils and body structures or
using dna to identify shared traits and
other similarities
the trees serve as models for studying
evolutionary relationships over time
so let's take a look at a tree that
scientists built for city pigeons also
called rock doves and their relatives
what can the tree tell us
how are doves and these other species
related
evolutionary trees are called trees for
a reason the evolutionary relationships
between lineages are represented by
branches showing who is related to whom
and to what degree
the tips of the branches of an
evolutionary tree show the modern groups
of organisms in this case we have doves
mesites and sand grouse
they all look different from one another
but you can see some physical traits
like their small bills that are similar
between all of these birds let's take a
look at this evolutionary tree what do
you think that this branch point means
the branch point or the place where
branches split represents common
ancestors that existed in the past among
these bird lineages from which these
modern-day birds evolved
mesites and sandgrouse shared a common
ancestor in the past about 60 million
years ago which is represented by a
branch point
but what does this branch point mean
exactly basically this branch point
represents that at some time in the
distant past at least 60 million years
ago a bird species existed that wasn't a
mesite or a sand grass but it did have
some traits found in both mesites and
sandgrass
this species was the common ancestor
at some point this common ancestor
species split and gave rise to two
different evolutionary paths or lineages
one of those paths gave rise to mesites
and the other led to sandgrass
and if we go even further back to about
65 million years ago we see yet another
branch point representing another common
ancestor
this common ancestor would later split
to form two lineages
one giving rise to doves and the other
leading to the common ancestor of
mesites and sandgrass
looking at this evolutionary tree we can
also learn about how closely related
different lineages are
organisms that share a common ancestor
in the more recent past are more closely
related to one another
but organisms that share a common
ancestor in the more distant past are
less closely related
the common ancestor of mesites and sand
groves existed in the more recent past
than the common ancestor of mesite
sandgrouse and doves this means that
mesits and sand graves are more closely
related to each other than they are to
doves
dinosaurs are far in the past now but
their relatives are still among us
all the birds that you see every day
evolved from a two-legged feathered
common ancestor that roamed the earth
over 165 million years ago with
dinosaurs
so the next time you see a rock dove
flying by or picking up scraps in a city
square you're really looking at a
dinosaur or at least a distant relative
of a dinosaur